das nächste und hj den fans meine drei
fragen nämlich wählen was sind deine
vorbilder im musikbusiness wer
inspiriert dich nicht ist das richtig
tolles deutsche oder auch recht
amerikanische stars so richtig gut
zuletzt oder auch aus einem anderen land
die ich vielleicht dazu gebracht haben
musik zu machen ich weiß ja nicht meine
nächste frage werde ich wie es sieht
dann als aktions was machst du
eigentlich den ganzen tag das war die
wirklich alles nur musik oder
irgendwelche anderen hobbys machst du
sport oder kürzlich mit einer freundin
irgendwie so was gibt es da vielleicht
was in deinem leben oder hast du gar
keine zeit wegen der musik ich weiß ja
nicht wie das so abläuft meine nächste
frage werde die würde der neben ablaufen
wenn du kein musiker wer also wissen job
solltest du aus dass da irgendein job
den ich sonst noch so gefällt die du
gerne machen würde aber hast du auch
irgendwie etwas gelernt irgendwie ja und
der ausbildung oder im abschluss gibt es
da was ich hoffe du kannst mir die
fragen beantworte ich bedanke mich bei
klick super dass die saalburg stellen
dürfte das warten wir was maske
danke nochmal man krieg ich lieber boss
maske erste frage ist
was geht ja mit der maske aber
inspirieren tut mich ja ich weiß es
nicht also ich glaube nicht dass ich
durch irgendwie ein bestimmtes zur musik
gekommen bin ich habe einfach das
einfach entschieden machen zu wollen und
meine mutter hat echt also ich hab meine
musik und meine mutter gehört hat und
der hat echt fürchterliche sache wie
heimchen und so sagen und wenn ich jetzt
sagen würde ich habe mich dazu gebracht
musik zu machen erstmal ein bisschen
komisch keine ahnung ich papas einfach
beschlossen zu machen und gab jetzt
nicht so vorbilder nachgeeifert bin
dann die zweite frage habe ich
anscheinend schon beantwortet was ich so
tue den ganzen tag ich mache musik ich
habe keine freizeit und die letzte frage
was ich machen würde ich nicht muss ich
machen würde dann wäre ich hab ich
keinen fahrer geworden und weiß das
klingt komisch aber es war das einzige
übernehme ich gedacht das könnte sie
wahrscheinlich auch noch so gut wie sie
und das hätte ich ohne witz versucht zu
schaffen wenn das irgendwann mit der
musik gescheitert wäre und ja auch noch
mal zu diesem freizeit ich verkleide
mich auch sehr gerne
und trage gerne auch so masken und wenn
wir uns mal treffen könnten zum
maskenball werde ich dir sehr verbunden
in diesem sinne hätten